(dramatic music)
(audience cheering)
(audience applauding)
- This place is amazing.
- [Kelly] Very festive.
- Very festive.
This is awesome.
- [Kelly] I kind of want to
hang those lights on my house,
the big giant ones, I
just think it'd be fun.
- [Andy] I kind of want to bring
this whole set home with me.
- I know, makes you happy.
Well, happy belated Hanukkah.
- Thank you very much.
You could fit like 30
or 40 versions of my set
in this studio.
- We lucked out, we
did, for a show this is,
we did, we lucked out.
I was very aware.
I walked in, I was like, "What?"
- You look beautiful,
this dress is amazing.
- Thank you, it's all fake news.
You've seen me without hair and makeup.
(laughing)
But, no.
So you, weeks ago, you, this
is first time for Benjamin.
Move the furniture wherever you want.
- Yeah, no problem.
Just making myself comfortable.
- Was this your first
time though that Benjamin,
like is he like really enjoying Hanukkah?
- He is, he's loving it.
He associates the candles
with a present after it.
- Of course.
- Yes, of course.
- [Kelly] Yeah, he's a kid.
- [Andy] There he is,
that was the other night.
- [Kelly] Oh my god, that face.
How do you not eat that face?
- I know, I do.
I try to chew his cheeks all the time.
Yeah, it's amazing.
- It's so fun.
Do y'all do Christmas as well?
- Well, we're figuring that out.
I stole a fake tree from my studio and so-
- [Kelly] Stealing, which is
a good Christmas thing to do.
- [Andy] Yeah, exactly.
But is it stealing if it's my studio?
- It's yours, no.
- Yeah, exactly.
That's the conversation.
- Oh, so it's a fake tree.
I do, look, I do pre-lit fake all the way.
- Me too.
I mean, I, me too.
I mean, I would feel too
guilty if it was a real tree.
- Well, some people,
I've learned actually,
Jay Leno just told me this,
he actually, his family would plant them.
They'd get it and then they'd plant it.
Like, they'd do it all by
the root system, but yeah.
- As a Jew, I don't feel
comfortable with that.
I barely feel comfortable
with a fake tree.
I'm like riding the line.
I am a Jew.
- Okay, I was just thinking pretty lights.
- I think pretty lights too.
That's all I'm thinking of too.
- I know, I just decorate.
And I think as a single mom, too,
like I put the whole thing up myself.
And those layers of the
fake tree, it's hard.
- Well, let me tell you
something, as a single dad,
I did it all myself too the other night.
- Oh my god, I almost broke my back.
- I did too.
It's ain't easy.
- Yeah, I'm short too,
so it's like get the-
- I'm not the tallest
guy in the world either.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- You know what?
- [Kelly] We should just call each other.
- We should get married.
- Okay, so was there a
toy growing up though,
that you really wanted?
Like around Christmas
time that you really?
- I always, I was a
big electric train kid.
- Oh, so is my son.
- Oh, really?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Electric trains and Snoopy is my jam.
- [Kelly] Oh, I love Snoopy.
- And I'm still very into Snoopy.
- Yeah.
- Yes.
- [Kelly] Why not?
- Why not?
- I never grew up either.
What is Benjamin obsessed with?
- He's into trucks and cars and, yes,
any vehicle is his thing.
- [Kelly] That's fun.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, why not?
- I love that.
I love playing with my.
I heard that, is he into "Frozen?"
- He's very into "Frozen."
- 'Cause I love that he's into "Frozen"
'cause I heard about this
and I wanted to tell you,
I took my kids on the
"Frozen" ride in Orlando.
As a 39-year-old woman, I
was like almost in tears
at the end of it.
It's so cool.
- Really?
- It's amazing what people are capable of.
The technology that they do now.
Like when we were kids, the
rides were so different.
Like, yeah.
Now they're like involved.
- The rides.
- [Kelly] The rides.
- The rides were so
different when we were kids.
- [Kelly] The rides.
- [Andy] The rides.
Um, yes.
- It's anytime I say I,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I like it, I love it.
- So Andy's new book is called
"Glitter Every Day: 365
Quotes from Women I Love."
So what inspired the
book other than women-
- Women that I love.
You know what?
It was the pandemic and I was thinking,
"What can I do that would bring me joy?"
And I've had so many
great females in my life
from my mom to divas that
I've grown up loving.
You're in the book.
- I heard I'm in the book.
- Housewives.
That I wanted to choose
little bits of glitter
that people could start
their day with a smile
or a little piece of inspiration.
And I love, Hoda Kotb has
a quote-a-day book out.
And it's very Hodi, it's very Hoda-esque.
And this is a little more Andy-esque.
- Yeah, I love that though.
Then you have something for everyone.
So, wait, you quoted me saying this,
I love that this is my quote.
- [Andy] I know, I know, right?
- [Kelly] "I worked at Six Flags.
"I did the singing and
dancing, like all the shows.
"Any option that was available
to make money singing,
"I was like, 'Okay.'"
- But I love that.
- No, but thank you.
'Cause that's true.
You should just keep
wassailing until you make it.
- And something that I love about you
is you never forgot where you came from
and you own your past.
I think that's really important.
And I think it's really one of the things
that we all love about you.
- Oh, well, thank you.
That was very cool.
So you started the book
off with the quote,
"Get ahold of yourself, Andy!"
And that's by your mother.
- Yes, Evelyn Cohen.
And that is, that is January 1st quote.
It's just like a slap in the face
whenever she says that to me, wake up.
- What?
Like, when is the time she
would usually say that?
- Just anytime I'm acting like a fool,
which is fairly often.
- That's what makes you fun.
- Thank you.
- Yeah.
- That's what I think is fun.
- Tell my mom.
- You can tell my mom too.
Help me, I'll help you.
So you said you went to
camp every summer as a kid.
I always wanted to be one of those kids.
That's so fun.
- What were you doing during summers?
- What all poor kids were doing.
Just hanging out in the street
playing basketball or something.
- All right.
Well, were you singing in the?
- In my, yeah, my first
studio was my closet
'cause it took up the sound.
I heard about that.
So that, yeah, I was just doing that.
Poor people things.
So what is something you
learned at camp though?
I always thought that was so cool.
- You know what, what I
really learned at camp
was independence.
I mean, I valued that.
Even if you grew up like Kelly,
if you get shipped off to
an aunt or an uncle's house,
just being away from my
family was so important,
as it turns out, for me to realize
that I could do things on my own.
And I loved it.
I thought it was really important.
Are you gonna find that harder,
now that you brought that up?
Like, so I did too.
I developed a lot of independence
because my mother was like basically-
- Miss independent.
- But yes, and then I
wrote a song about it.
- Yeah.
- No, but I love though
that while I talk about that freedom,
I literally was outside all day
until I had to be home before the dark,
like before the sun went down.
And so I'm like,
I want my kids to experience
that kind of freedom,
but it's hard to do that now.
Like, so how do you, how
are you gonna get Benjamin
to have that kind of independence?
- That's a really good question.
I mean, and he's a city
kid, which I was not.
I grew up in St. Louis.
And so I don't know the answer to that,
but I'm going to, I'm gonna push for it.
- Gonna go to therapy to learn.
I'm just kidding.
Me too.
So let's do some more
quotes from your book.
So this one's from Tina Fey.
I love her.
And I love this quote.
"You can tell how smart people
are by what they laugh at."
- Oh, I live by that.
I mean, on, when I'm on dates with people,
I always want to know
what they think is funny
and what shows they watch.
And it's a great way to figure out, to me,
are we gonna be able to hang together?
- Yeah.
It's very a clever way of
picking the weeds, yeah.
- [Andy] Yes, absolutely.
- Yeah.
I'm not good at that.
I'm always like that person
that's like, "Oh, I don't know.
"Maybe they have an off
day or like maybe like."
I'm always like, yeah.
- Yeah.
- I cut and run.
- I should, we should
hang out so it rubs off.
So wait, are you more, you
said you're a tea guy, right?
Not like a coffee guy.
- Yeah, that's correct.
- But you like cocktails, right?
- I love cocktails.
- Okay.
- Absolutely, yes.
- Have you ever tried alcohol and tea?
- No, have you?
- Okay, like a hot toddy,
isn't that kind of like
what a hot toddy kind of is?
- Yeah, kind of, yeah, no, I haven't.
- Oh, it's really good, anyway.
Well, this is, I heard
that you like cocktails,
so I thought that was.
That's a better first
date kind of thing too
'cause then I feel like
people open up, right?
- For sure.
There's a Chelsea Handler quote
in the book about just that.
She's saying basically
denouncing coffee dates,
and I totally agree.
I like a boozy first date.
So you let your guard
down and you kind of,
when you look at someone,
I know, you have to,
well, you have to control yourself.
- Beer goggles aren't, are often-
- Yes, exactly.
- Yeah.
- Clear beer goggles.
- [Kelly] Do those exist?
- I don't know.
I might be more of like a
coffee person to be like,
I don't know if I'm willing to invest
in like an evening with you yet.
- [Andy] Right.
- Maybe like a 10:30, 11.
- Yes, one drink, one drink, one drink.
- Yeah, okay, okay.
I shall be single forever.
So this is, this is a quote
that you have from Kathy Bates,
another woman I love.
"Never share a joint with a stranger,
"even if they're famous,
especially if they're Bill Maher."
- Yes.
Well, Bill Maher, I think,
gets grade A pot, yes.
- So she's like, "You're
gonna get so messed up."
- Yes, exactly.
- Okay.
- [Andy] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Well, that's just, she's
not up for the challenge
I feel like.
- I feel like Kathy Bates is
up for the challenge, yeah.
- I love Kathy.
- Yeah, me too.
- She came here and I was like,
"I want to drink with you."
- [Andy] Oh, she's amazing.
- Yeah, she's so fun.
So wait, so why, do you
agree with that or no?
- I love that quote,
but it also gave me an
opportunity to humble brag
in the book about, I have a
great list of famous people
that I've gotten high with.
And so I wanted to put it
in the book, basically.
- Now, that's a great first date thing
to see who you really are.
- [Andy] Yes, yeah, exactly, yes, yeah.
- Yeah.
So wait, one, I want to know like a story.
- So Snoop Dogg is on the list.
- Oh god.
- Bob Weir from the Grateful Dead.
- Now, I have a question.
With Snoop Dogg, did you actually get high
or just a contact high?
'Cause I've been around him.
- Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
Yes, no, I've gotten the contact high,
but I actually got high.
And his manager turned to me and said,
"Just one, just take one hit.
"You honestly."
- You will not be able to walk.
- Right, exactly, yes, yeah.
- [Kelly] He and Bill Maher.
- Yeah, exactly.
- So wait, so, okay, I
want to pick up this book
because I love, first
of all, I love that the,
why "Glitter Every Day"?
I love that.
- Well, it's just like a
little piece of glitter every,
every day of the year, 365 quotes.
It such a cool idea, man.
Andy's new book, "Glitter
Every Day" is out now.
Y'all gotta check it out.
And you can see Andy host
"Watch What Happens Live"
Sundays through Thursdays on Bravo.
It's hilarious.